laughs
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
hello
oh man dude
[Music]
is OBS just being stupid
[Music]
I can't tell man shoot
[Music]
you guys hear me
[Music]
hello
[Music]
man bro
[Music]
is my internet bad or something there's
no way
how does it look chat is it like
buffering or anything
[Music]
for you
I'm getting drop frames here
listen
[Music]
looks fine it's perfect
no buffering
man dude I hate it when OBS is just like
hey here's a red bar and a bunch of drop
frames that keep increasing and it's
just not
I guess
[Music]
the audio is buffering
that I have no idea was what that would
be I don't know why the audio would
buffer at all
that doesn't even make sense actually
God
so the mute how is the music choppy what
I'm in my new place so today is gonna be
a day
dude I am directly plugged into my
internet how is it even remotely bad
are you kidding me right now bro
yep life's on Buffer right now it is
um I don't I don't know what to do I I
might need to restart obs
I might need to we'll see how it's going
I think
uh
man bro
[Music]
really
I think OBS just might be messing with
me bro I just don't like it when it does
that you know I mean it's really
stupid man
hi
I'm in the new place
here we are
how's it going
I love it here man
whew
new house
new apartment
who texted me
I like your new apartment it's big and
spacious oh thank you okay
is that sun yeah
that's the Sun
not a lot I can do about the sun my guy
not a lot I can do about the sun yep
please let me know if the stream's like
buffering and weird and looks bad and we
today's gonna be a test type of day okay
I didn't want to end the stream because
then I would have to remake the stream
which would be bad
which wouldn't be that bad I just delete
this one and then go to the next one
foreign so hopefully it's good man
hopefully it's good I was two or one out
of ten let me unmount my camera and take
you around the place my guy
with the longest chord in existence
where can I read how was your date
chat my date canceled on me dog
if you're referring to the date from the
other day
cancel
I got I didn't get stood up but
she said no
or like had to do something else
so I was just like
I I didn't have to end the stream or
anything this is lame
like all right fine he did reschedule
for this week
but now it's just like
who knows
you know what I mean
blue bald no not a blue ball situation
not a blue ball situation but I don't
know
we'll see
sorry that happened it's not a big deal
it's not a big deal
oh you guys want a video
of the apartment
it's a pretty big apartment man like the
I don't have a dining room like my setup
is in where the dining room would be
living room patio huge ass patio out
here
kitchens right there really nice kitchen
um bedrooms over there like around this
wall that way with the bathroom right
there too it's pretty nice
I'm so this is like one of the nicest
places I've ever lived in so I'm really
happy with it hopefully the internet's
better than what it's given me right now
[Music]
and then a friend of mine uh Katie gave
me this playlist
it's like nostalgic
PlayStation Nintendo remix uncopyrighted
songs
so I hope you like it
at least you have your sugar
Brew Joy's not here yet by the way not
yet
I am gonna go have dinner with my
parents tonight and then um I'm gonna go
pick her up and bring her here
is this megalovania yes it is
you called it angel
hi Peter how are you man but I hope
everyone's doing good uh I've been
moving as you can see for the last few
days
that was a lot
a lot going on lately
uh
actually the entire
the entire moving process went like as
good as it could
literally no problems
no problems at all
um
what is that word on the mic
you mean the arm right here
I don't know whatever company this is
made by
um
[Music]
yeah I thought we'd just continue uh our
boy
Perry hotter today while we uh see how
we're doing
see I basically a test stream today guys
okay
first stream in the new place
see how it's going man I hope it's
it doesn't crash completely on us at
some point here
that would be bad
but I miss Perry hotter bro
Perry hotter is a g
[Music]
m
[Music]
how's the maiden date dude you guys all
remembered this date huh
that's crazy
well it didn't happen does anyone just
come in now it didn't happen man
unfortunately hopefully it'll happen
this week
a gentleman of musical culture I suppose
so man I suppose so if I helped
Millicent yet
Dark Soul ashes of Aryan Dell trailer
the mod seems like a new game
is it called Ash's variantale I thought
it was called something else
what's up brief how are you
you killed her nah she right there bro
be good
well
I don't know about good but she's okay
oh Arch Thrones I did see that I
definitely want to play that
100 percent
so whenever that becomes an option
I'm playing it a hundred percent
that looks sick
like a new game but it's just a mod
it's like kind of incredible how do I I
remember being able to get down from
here I think I have to go this way
though
you can't run away from Melania
yeah we know
well actually
I don't know you never have to fight
Millennia ever
she's a totally optional
boss
more Millennia tries
is that what you're saying there
I mean I'll fight millennia
I'm just not a fan of Melania As We Know
she is a part of the game oh more rants
no I'm not gonna complain anymore
we all know my opinion of Millennia she
is uh
amazing right
I always fall right there
idiot
Idiot still have to leave the frenzied
Flame
oh it's optional until you have to leave
the frenzied Flame
well true yeah if you don't if you want
to cancel it yeah
so in that context it's not optional
good point can you jump torrent oh my
God I swear sometimes I press the input
for torrent and he just doesn't jump
he just doesn't do it
he's like yeah I'm lazy
I don't wanna
just beat New Game Plus Melania again
because I'm farming somber ancients but
damn the fight is annoying no matter how
open I am dude the first time I fought
Melania was a new game plus one
so that was great had a great time doing
that
it's this Tower up here right yeah
that opens that door I don't really even
need to open the store but whatever
will Melania be able to try one platform
section for the front seat plan
would Melania be able to one try the
platform section
um maybe in her second face
where she can fly
I don't know it seems like she flies in
her first phase when she does waterfowl
you know
okay so now we have that open that makes
that a little easier I guess
now let's go talk to uh our boy over
here
me having never fought my lady
I mean
go for it if you want
have a great time with that
why can't I use this okay there we go
I'm gonna kill the dog
those dogs still haunt my dreams
scary as hell
oh
a pleasure to see you a pleasure indeed
how we looking guys OBS is still telling
me that we're crashing hard but you guys
are saying it looks fine so now I'm just
nervous and freaked out when one of your
ilk came along
not sure but torrent looks like a
mountain goat
yeah it's Horn's a mix of everything
resting
mcmillus for this oh we want the
Scorpion charm huh
the secret
so it's hidden and I will tell secret
well can I just go get it like do I even
have to talk to him before this
I haven't really done it that much
I guess I don't have to do this Quest
why I think we were up here because we
wanted the Dex Medallion like that's got
to be good for a sorcerer build right a
wizard build
Millicent's Medallion It's gotta be good
right
okay let's see how this goes
I don't really like it here in the dark
I mean that doesn't really matter for me
hmm
all right let me do this
now and I'm gonna do this
okay that wasn't really helpful let's do
this
honestly roxling was the best
right
I'll try this too
not great
not great
slightly framed now that stutter overall
it's fine wait GB how can you tell my
thing
or that's your thing
I don't know
well OBS is saying it's fine now
I didn't change anything
and the game is really different as a
wizard
really different
do anything there I should have a weapon
where I can if I get somebody staggered
I can go and and do something with it
hmm
well that didn't reach bro
wait I think he summons the other guys
with that
where are they there they are okay
stats for nerds and that shows my stuff
I did not know that
I always just go off obs
pretty sure that would have killed me
oh I'm dead
I'm dead as [ __ ]
there we go
hold everybody holding
these guys are fast as hell damn
okay
no
okay
where do I get the arrows talisman
uh oh I'm dead
here we go
okay
one more
hopefully that reach that'll reach there
we go
wow
this is a totally different game as a
wizard
man bro
well thank you Irby
so it increases Rock sling bubble magic
ranged by a tousman well we use a lot of
rock slings so that could help us
we could do that
near evergale Crucible night at
Stormville that's right it's up um
at that gate Tower right
if I'm looking at it here so it's this
here
and like up on these
yeah
I guess I could go get it
let's go get it why not
where's the Perry his name is Perry who
does not Parry
he doesn't Parry yet
maybe at some point he will Parry
maybe at some point man
oh it's good to be back streaming guys
it's good moving is really hard
I would recommend to you to just not
move if you don't have to
and and my whole move went about as
clean and good as it could
carry in retaliation
that's only good against magic builds
though right
like if they use sorceries against you
then it's great
but if it's this guy
not really the best you know what I mean
sir I ask you to calm down
hmm
let's see this
damn
I'm a strong wizard
it works against a standard Perry
oh it works for that as well you kidding
me
that's great
I didn't know that
a bunch of Ricks up here I'm pretty sure
it's in here
okay
oh we already have good talismans though
but we have it on Deck
that'll be good we already got this
which you guys said is good but I need
52 int
holy titties man
holy titties
I don't want it to be dark anymore
no Darkness
the other Talisman is at the bridge
wooden near the Redan teleported in
caled
that's a right it's uh
we already fought we're done holy [ __ ]
we're amazing
it's
kind of near here it's this right well
we got to go this way anyway
I'll just slap that there excellent
why do you have the filigreed you aren't
using the ash of War
dog you just said words I don't
understand
it's not there
down at the bridge to radon's Castle
really
then what's up here nothing
dumb I'm gonna find out
torrent
you hoe
might need to close the curtain behind
me because there is a slight glare on my
screen
you found the unalloyed Golden Needle as
promised freaking OBS man
right here yeah guys like the shrimp go
on go ahead and give it a like just real
quick go ahead and hit the like
did I already open the secret welcome
can you give me I wish there was
different dialogue if you do certain
things
can you give me as well mate okay watch
this chat
we'll come back in and he'll be like Oh
I'm all done
where'd you go sorcery and Elden ring
carrying spell to cancel enemy spells
while attacking them with the projectile
so it doesn't
Parry normal attacks as well
[Music]
excellent intended to a wretched
let's go over here and then we'll help
um mommy Millicent
I want to see what's up here though I'm
curious now
oh wait how do I get up there
I have to go up on that Hill
which I can go to
by Millicent [ __ ]
never like the video
something is wrong with you
imagine not liking the Stream
tragic
tragic man
it's hearsay
okay
foreign
golden Perry is much better in that case
can I switch between potentially
um
okay I guess I'll help Nelson First
hi Joe
quit whining
millicently My Flesh rides with garlic
trot swap the Talisman which one
stop but never mind
I've decided I would rather trust you
chat is Caleb Ohio or Florida you just
spoiled from within
averting your eyes for a moment
it's exactly what Melania does in the
trailer she stabs herself
you guys remember the Elden Ring trailer
so [ __ ] hype I don't think I've ever
been as hype as I was for that
so [ __ ] cool
it's hell
never liked vids or streams until yours
unlike for bigger streamers for you it
actually makes a difference well what if
I was a big streamer man that's the goal
to be a big streamer
I would say I'm bigger than most
on YouTube there's a lot of people who
stream on YouTube to like nobody same on
Twitch
this is pretty
grew up in Florida Kayla is Florida I
feel you
I lived in Florida
I probably won't live in Florida again
I only lived there for like a year
though
I didn't like it
I thought it was Russia
you know what it's Caleb that's what it
is
does this giant give me anything cool
over here
it's kind of a weirdo
the first Talisman isn't doing anything
for you
the fact that it's making you so mad is
the reason I'm not changing it
why are there invisible Wizards over
here what the frig
oh and okay of course of course
this is scary
all right
physical damage is good
how
ah no oh [ __ ]
foreign
well at least it's not dark anymore
man you think after as many playthroughs
and hours as I have done I wouldn't fall
to gravity I watched the entire Elven
or
Rune roulette streams I'm so sorry you
had to deal with Melania
what do you mean dude that was easy
we didn't have any problems against her
dude
just had to grind got it done man
easy stuff you know you know what I'm
saying
all right guys
I need a sword
don't I
it's a generous spot for that
I'm trying to Blind hit him
okay what else can I use here
I wish they weren't [ __ ] Wizards man
[ __ ] okay
we definitely need something else
besides this
okay good enough
we got one
do I have the carrying blade
Zoom clintstone blade did I not fight
renali yet
didn't I kill Ronaldo chat I don't
remember
ignore the voice break there
all right well I'm using this
I put it on the wrong thing didn't I son
of Beach
that and that
excellent
where are you
okay
see how much see how helpful that is
dude I need to remember how to stream
we'll get there boys
okay the sword's kind of poopy but it
gets the job done
hey what am I up here for
where is this thing
there's gotta be more to this
is there chest over here chest
best ladder
no
okay you guys wanted me to change this
so This does nothing for me you're
saying
and now you just switch it with this
the stuff you can't see
I don't need this
lowers FP consumed by skills
well I guess I'm not using skills I'm
using spells
let's try it
keep going
okay
oh I see
there's a bunch of goats
a bunch of goots
oh
chat
chat
what'd you do to me man
oh
God
I died
you bamboozled me
nice
we tried to warn you well I didn't
listen obviously
well this must be a really good item
what is that
Eternal Darkness
well this is a pretty scene right here
what does that do
creates dark space that draws in spells
oh I've seen this before
yeah it sucks up spells
we already went through the academy
though right yeah we did
so where's that sword the the one that
the dude uses
do I just not have it or does he only
give me the shield
do I only get the shield from that guy
outside of ranala this one
I'm just misremembering
he only gives you a shield okay I
thought you got both from him
interesting
would you say that would be a good sword
to get though or is this one good
should I use sword of Knight and Flame
with this build
we could we could get there man
it could be interesting
along with the staff
it's somewhere else thank you that's
very helpful actually is
y'all you always find it I feel like I
do too and that's like I don't remember
where it is because of that
it's a really good int sword okay
one place where the person talks to that
one character who's connected to that
one girl okay thank you Paul
excellent
very good
okay I'm gonna great bow this guy real
quick everybody watch everybody hold you
ready
yeah ignore that
I'm regretting this decision
regretting
instantaneous regret happening right now
oh yeah
you don't stagger like that though huh
I'm way up in there
where is my sword bro
hello
did I take it off
I don't remember taking it off
man I'm stupid sometimes
there we go
I really am stupid
nothing
even with him up here he usually throws
pots at you
he's up here with these pots and you get
nothing for killing him
pain
you guys know there are people out there
that say this game looks ugly
crazy
a physic am I working with here
I'll get it checked
carrion slicer
oh you're right I forgot about that
and I have that excellent
why don't you have magic pots
I don't know it reminds me of when
people tell me to use Frost pots and
then I get mad and just don't do it
the graphics are dog [ __ ] Quantum TV
what a guy huh
what what a what a person
okay let's see what millison's got going
on
not worth it not even for the runes
all that whole Quantum TV act man thing
everything is as you said
since inserting the needle the Scarlet
rot has ceased to writhe even the
nightmares have abated what a Time how's
the new apartment I [ __ ] love it here
Nando's
this is my like favorite place I've ever
lived
yep
Iowa token though it is the guy the guy
reviews TVs
why would he have an opinion on Eldon
ring
you can always have an opinion but
what
what are the chances you guys think that
that Quantum TV played all of Elden ring
he played the game
I think you have to play a game from
start to finish to actually have a to to
make an entire review about it right
like I'm not making an entire review
about Dark Souls 2 because I've never
finished it however I can't say that I
did not enjoy my time but I wouldn't
make a review
on it
that is a goal this year by the way to
finish Dark Souls 2. he said he doesn't
play then how can you make a review on
something that you didn't finish
that's so weird
did I already go in that cave back there
I think I did I don't know what I'm
doing right now where are we
when are you playing Dark Souls 2
whenever I get my [ __ ] together and I
just do it bro
that that's where I'm at on that
I just gotta do it man didn't he admit
he didn't get past the tree Sentinel
dude there's no way
like he had to have had the the concept
of just running away
from the tree Sentinel
that has to be a thing
or are there a lot of people that just
didn't like they they couldn't beat the
tree Sentinel and they think they
couldn't do anything else and just
stopped
because that that's some silly [ __ ] if
that's the case
did I already go get the golden seeds
and everything
he might appear behind you man
that's fine with me
I'll have a nice discussion with him
about opening
and you know yeah he said like it
wouldn't win game of the year and
everybody would stop talking about it
in a couple of weeks right
and honestly that game turned out to be
God of War
that is that
is that me to me to say because God of
War is such a good game
but nobody I I don't want to play it
again I don't hear anybody talking about
it anymore
I've got a one
like you know that's it kind of worked
out that way didn't it
I'm not fighting these guys
oh man
that's funny
laughs
oh I did pick these up chat I just
didn't hit this right here
oh Archie are yeah
I don't I wouldn't say Elden ring died
at all there's still a lot of interest
in this game
it's not as big as it was obviously but
this game's big
it got a nice influx of players when it
won game of the year too by the way and
went on sale which is super rare
for uh from software to put their games
on sale
foreign
I don't know why I'm going up here I
don't think I need this but I'm going up
here because I want to and I think it's
pretty
is that a good enough reason for you
I think unironically this is one of the
DLC locations chat
we'll go here
and do something with this tree I
haven't heard anyone else say that
but
I think this is where a DLC will start
we'll do something with that tree and go
somewhere else but you know what I mean
he's still riding the train of Elden
ring being garbage of course he is
that's the only reason he's uh
talked about
you know
so of course he's going to do that if
he's a narcissistic attention or which I
think he is
then uh he'll ride that train till he
can't anymore
he'll die on that Hill
I think is crazy
91k that's really good Rob
considering
that's great actually
oh did it Grim I haven't seen that
before
it goes on sale sometimes I was
surprised they already put Elder ring on
sale
but it made sense Game of the Year
people it piques their interests uh
and then they see it's on sale they buy
it
the people who didn't before
wait I already got this
dude I'm blind stupid and
just like all that like what I just said
I'm an idiot
I might want to try and beat this Dragon
Sentinel chat
I'm gonna try it
what's hilarious is the Mischief guy he
targeted commented now he has like 80k
more subs than him yeah that's because
of act man though
and he makes good videos too
yep another wave of people
getting mad at markets
what's new man
have you ever considered to play the
game of the year winning Japanese indie
game called Elden ring
nah dude I haven't heard of it
is it is it a good game
oh that hit me bam
the wheel of pain run mess you up it
really did it actually did
I can't wait for Elder and GLC police
Miyazaki give us a quick DLC
I don't want him to make a quick DLC
[ __ ] that
[Music]
take as much time as you need to make a
bomb VLC or a new game
I'm cool with a new game too
hold on I'm gonna use slicer on this guy
okay maybe I'm not gonna use slicer on
this guy
[Music]
yeah maybe I don't use slicer on the sky
how are your wizard with only leveling
Vigor read the title again and then come
back to me
Archies
read the title again
you can do it
and then this just makes a video about
Elder ring is sexist I did see that
video
I did see that
people have some opinions huh
people in their opinions man they got a
lot of them
do carrion slicer is ridiculous
oh
okay I almost died there
okay now we'll back up
foreign
oh yeah
no
only one hit him
okay there you go Archies
good stuff man
okay that's kind of annoying
not really getting what I want here
freaking horse man
whoa
you see that
[Music]
I don't know what to do
I'm bad at switching
uh that was my fault
I'd rather not die right here
[Music]
okay
no
okay
there we go
man this is a different game chat
as a wizard
I'm starting to have fun with it
still better than twin gargles in
Orlando
dude no kidding
how's the build going it's pretty fun
Mike I'm having a good time
I couldn't see how I could possibly win
yeah I think I got to I think I got here
at like level 45 somehow in my first
playthrough
it's hard to remember it's been almost a
year
uh and I think I spent like two and a
half hours you know like you guys know
me just beating my head against the wall
until I beat him
then uh finally did but it like level 45
I'm like what am I doing I should have
just left
uh there is a Max upgrade for the
Glenstone Pebble at Ryan Lucario near
the debate parlor
Max upgrade for glintstone Pebble
ooh do you think that's like is that
worth it
now there are people who actually think
eldering is sexist
yep
yep
[Music]
that's the thing
it's a big problem
okay what do I want to level I don't I
don't just want to put levels and stuff
what do I want to use
did I use sort of Knight in flame chat
as my secondary
or is it not even worth it since I have
the sword thing
um
not glintstone Comet just comment didn't
I already have that
didn't already picked that up
no because yes that's an answer
it's a good one
[Music]
I already have that guys and we were
just like yeah it's not that good yeah
it's right here
comet
I tried it and it was just like eh mid
oh it's 52 inch okay there there we go
very area
nope read the title again Ethan we gotta
get to 500 members if we want to do a
Vigor only run
I don't know how that's gonna go but
we're gonna try it
if we get there
all right intelligence it is
I thought it'd be funny after doing that
uh Joe
I thought it'd be funny
because we couldn't decide on like
double bosses which could be fun too
I think a Vigor only run would be
actually pretty funny
yes Ethan
you can raise your int with a glint Zone
crown
I think I have that
we'll get there we're leveling it I know
I can be uh Godfrey's
you know glowy Godfrey what do you guys
call this guy
I just call him glowy God
I don't know why
[Music]
Melina history
My Utmost thanks goldfried for bringing
me to the base of the earth tree that's
better than mine I can govern my own
movement and thus
Gold free record right is fulfilled I
shall depart you're welcome to ascertain
the purpose all right Chad be honest was
the stream lagging
are we still looking okay you know I can
look at it too
I have a phone with you
I'm a little upset that we I think it's
OBS being stupid
I think it is
I'm telling you guys OBS is one of the
best but also one of the worst
uh
what would you call it
apps
of all time
I'm looking at the stream currently
everyone say hi to me even though I'm
literally here looking at you
1440p
okay
we're up
okay
I have nothing to put it on and put it
right there
okay
I'll get on your end
excellent
no that okay
it's not let it's not lagging
hmm
it looks good to me
[Music]
still looking
hmm
not gonna lie chat at least on my phone
the stream looks good as hell
damn
might have to take my stream on a date
[ __ ]
all right oh I need to get out of here
first
when you skip an ad are you getting ads
I hope so
I think what I'm gonna start doing Chad
is playing like a legit ad once an hour
because YouTube definitely wants me to
do that
and then we can see the difference in
the Stream
gotta do a lot of research
is YouTube live streaming
still very new
very very new
oh God I hate this attack
whoops
you heard me say it
come on bro
can't be worse than twitch ads
no it'll be nothing like that they're
always skippable
always skippable ads
I always turn on that option
there's also probably a lot of settings
I need to mess around with in OBS like
it's a new place we'll figure it out
all is well
all is well
I'm so tired of putrid avatars
they have a lot of them don't they
so happy you know it's stream on Twitch
I'm happy I don't have to
I think there is definitely a culture on
YouTube that is not used to live
streaming yet but
we can change that because we're poggers
all right guys
we're freaking sick
[Music]
foreign
damn
that hurt
your avatar oh the entire game's musical
lineup is amazing Archies the the whole
thing
the entire game
has great music and yet lost to God of
War
I will never stop talking about that
ever
there's hot tub streamers hmm
I don't know man
they can make money however they want
but kind of weird to have on a live
streaming video game platform don't you
think
okay there we go no I haven't played
Hollow Knight
heard it's good though
got up what now
oh man
oh man
you guys think I should use a shield
Maybe
like should I use that Korean Shield
and then put car in retaliation on it
yeah I should have got the seed I'm kind
of dumb
I'll get it
what's your favorite weapon category big
sword
big sword
that's my favorite
oh [ __ ]
I think the silver mirror Shield's gonna
be too big for us Mike
[Applause]
wait
is he not gonna jump me okay there we go
there we go
it's like hello
did you guys watch my short today
foreign
I don't know how that jump worked but it
did
whoops
okay
this spell is ridiculous guys
shoot
Oh I thought I'd kill him there we go oh
my God that spell is ridiculous guys
holy moly well I got another Talisman
pouch
hold on should I put on the uh raises
decks
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
Gold free is dead easy peasy
literal chump absolute chump
level
how much intelligence winner 51
let's go get that seed
let's go get that seed it's right here
the music did not line up with the fight
I don't think it did actually
doesn't Harry have a sword it's right
here
oh I'm funny
pick up the runes
I didn't die
[Music]
forehead
probably talking about the short
let's see how that Short's doing by the
way
it like YouTube uh
YouTube shorts are weird but they're
definitely pushing them really [ __ ]
hard
I've gotten so many messages it's doing
really good holy [ __ ] oh my God
that was fast
good thing you picked up your runes yep
yep
uh I keep getting like messages from
YouTube they they're definitely just
wanting to push shorts super hard so
I'm gonna listen to him
hmm
everybody hold
everybody hold
damn it's doing good on Tick Tock too
I don't really care that much about Tick
Tock but
it's fun to put it up there
I wish shorts displayed on the Bell
notification on PC
Bell notification
oh do you not get notified when I post a
short
why is most social media trying to
recreate Tick Tock because it uh is an
insane
uh growth
platform like uh
they're gonna like so what they're doing
on YouTube is they're gonna they're
gonna start running ads in between
shorts
um if you didn't know that that's what
they've told me
um not in between all of them but just
kind of like you guys ever notice when
you're scrolling on Tick Tock if you're
on Tick Tock you you'll you'll get your
normal tick tocks and then you'll
randomly get like a sponsored ad right
that's made by Tick Tock they'll hire uh
creators to make their ads for free it's
really [ __ ] weird I'm sure they pay
them actually but in a different way
um
YouTube's gonna start doing that
so it's going to make them a
boatload of money that's why they're
doing it
that's why
should I do this in here I think I
should right do I get Bernal
bernal's a homie g no cap on a scat cap
school squillo no I have to do the whole
questline
oh wait isn't this really good for me
foreign
look at this man
damn
Harry hotter looking thick all right
let's go get that thing you guys wanted
me to get how about that
let's go Gramps
I don't think I get notifications for
shorts I think that's fine because it's
like it's a different algorithm it like
it it's it's either gonna push it or
it's not gonna push it
I had one short that I made I actually
unlisted it a really really long time
ago
called uh
it was where it was so dumb but it got a
quarter million views
where I said that the map looked like a
finger
like I drew an outline stuff like that I
was like this is gonna blow your mind
because I was a cringe Fest back then
kill Ronnie no I love her
the math does look like a finger by the
way
forget how I get down here
yeah I got a quarter million views out
of nowhere like just gone like for no
reason and it it sat at like 1500 views
for two weeks and then all of a sudden
quarter Mill
same thing happened with my normal radon
video which is my most successful video
by the way for the first it was three
weeks actually the first three weeks
that that radon video was out chat it
was at 500 views total
now it's at let me look
it's my most successful video
he was at 500 views total for three
weeks
and I'm like man it flopped bro that
kind of sucks
now
it is at 919
000 views
nuts
so almost a milli what up Trey how are
you sir
really put a good perspective yeah I
didn't take it too too serious I made
that video in like an hour
which
with that input to perspective now I
make videos that get 30 000 views then
they take me a week to make total
oh
short content is the meadow
um
no they just want it circled into your
content
you don't have to though
good stuff Trey good stuff I am charged
with maintaining these ghastly dolls
dolls Oh by the way chat I'm getting a
big ass couch right here
it's so it's a it's three eight foot
sectional couch
so it'll be like it'll start here
like here actually
go this and then it'll go eight feet
this way and then eight feet more this
way
it's it's a free couch though so I'm all
about it it's a big ass couch I'm so
like we gotta hire movers to get it over
here though it's too big
for sure
all right we want this yeah
yeah
and then let's go put it on our thingy
on our Shield
and then we'll upgrade our Shield
how's the new place I love it here this
I am so happy here it's so cozy
it's my own place feels good
you make a lot of memories on that couch
y'all make a lot of memories sitting
here while you guys look at the couch
we'll make memories doing that yeah how
about that
did someone really come in here and say
what is this video are you kidding me
this look like a video to you sir
what do I need 10 strength are you
pissing
are you [ __ ] kidding me about
how much strength do I have
eight
I'm a weak little [ __ ]
Bros dyslexic I am dyslexic don't make
fun of me
how'd your date go yeah
why you all remember my date
the date didn't happen
stop rubbing it in man
I didn't go on the date because she
canceled
bad
stop talking about it
I know you just got here though it's
okay
does Jake have a girlfriend no I do not
I do not have a girlfriend I am single
as a pringle
I wish I wasn't though
I wish I wasn't single
I've been single for a long time
long time
I guess it didn't go well I we didn't go
on the date she did reschedule for this
week though
I want to go and fight Reichard that's
what I'm doing told you you were ugly
I'm not ugly and you know it
I know it too I'm not ugly
I would tell y'all if I was ugly I'm not
I know it
is this what I'm telling myself I'm
gonna go this way
I don't want to go all the way to
volcano Manor
I wish I was a little bit taller wish I
was a baller
Jake is a seven
that's really good isn't it
a seven
that's good
watch I'm gonna start hitting the gym
hard as [ __ ] I already went this morning
we have like at this apartment complex
we have a
amazing gym it's got everything and
nobody was in there
it was great
I got a trip to Mexico in two months
chat I gotta look really good so I'll at
least be an 8 out of ten and then when I
get back from Mexico I'll be tan and
then I'll be like an 8.5
think about that
hmm
I don't know
do I want to go this way and lose all my
runes I don't really care about this
many runes to be honest with you
it's not a big deal
because we're gonna be godskin Noble
we're gonna fight Reichard
okay
it's fine
you gotta grab me though grab me
this is not grabbing
ma'am
yes
grab me
you're hot as hell
thanks man
okay listen I know I'm not hot as hell
but I I know I'm not ugly
I'm gonna try and be hot as hell though
I think I can that's the thing
chat
my date's mad
that she thinks she's a piece of [ __ ]
now
and you guys made her feel that way
because you kept bringing up the date
she's messaging me right now because
she's watching the Stream
she said sorry for canceling I'm a piece
of [ __ ] I know
what now I gotta tell her she's not
that's your fault chat
she's got a full-time job and she's
going to school it's okay
she had to cancel
fine
oh I'm dead aren't I
I am not dead
tell her we're buttholes I mean she just
saw that message
so now she knows that you think you're a
butthole
never hurt his feelings again
Chad I can't be hurt more than I already
have been
foreign
at this point in my life okay
I've been through the ringer
nothing really gets to me anymore man
I promise
it's all good
it's all good
chat want Jake to be single to play more
Elden ring
I mean I'm not gonna date a girl that
won't let me play games
so what like just think of that chat I
can't date a girl that doesn't like
video games right
so that brings the potential
for
being with someone for me
dramatically done
dramatically like every girl I've talked
to in the last year
are like okay so what do you do for a
living
I'm like oh I'm I'm a YouTuber and
they're like what
what's that
are you like Jake Paul
do you vlog
I'm like
no I I play video games oh my God my
ex-boyfriend played so much Call of Duty
it was so annoying
oh my God ow
he played so much Call of Duty
never pay attention to me
okay he's just grinding through that huh
she has a fair point I know
but it's the [ __ ] uh
you know they don't know anything
besides like Call of Duty and their
ex-boyfriend used to play it or whatever
foreign
I don't know where to walk right now
okay here we go
he's so fat that every Rock's gonna hit
him by the way so that's good
I guess
foreign
I'm not used to using May
everything's fine chat everything is
fine
uh I'm gonna use something else
body shaming
stop
366 why is that so weak
let's see let's slice them up boys
let me get in there
he's so fat
I hate that move
okay
why is he faster than the skinny one can
anyone answer that
hey watch this guys
don't look yet don't look yet
okay
what the f he went directly through what
scared me
okay never mind don't look
look
[Music]
okay
that didn't go well
oh now I gotta run all the way back up
bro I just realized that you
[Music]
I just realized that
uh
um
I think Rock sling was going better
than most everything else
thoughts
comments concerns
he's weak to bleed Frost and Slash
foreign
at least not that much
do you think the slicers are best bet
it could be actually
I'm gonna slice them up I'm gonna slice
them up boys
I I got his move set
I got his new set
sleep
I've got to do a sleep frostpot build
someday don't I
he's weak against your stunning looks
thank you
that was sweet
that was sweet I forgot what I was using
try burning him the marshmallow
[Music]
look at that
uh-huh
uh-huh
why did that hit me
I don't understand
okay I guess you can just throw directly
through a [ __ ] wall right
good to know man
that's really good to know
his arm went through the wall
I guess the godskin
are fencers
as well
where's the lore on that
oh
I don't like where I am right now
that hit me dude
okay please get stuck
right there sir
I hate it here
[Music]
he's so fat
another roll
I didn't ask for seconds
oh I'm so dumb bro
all right slicer's looking good boys
looking real good
mm-hmm
that's not good
okay let's not die let's not do that
that's dumb
what is that attack
I think it's silly
[Music]
that's a roll
I can't be too close
I don't know the distance man oh
can I lock on please
easy peasy
easy peasy
easy peasy guys all right let's see
I can't say
okay
guys she said
she said fun fact I won't pay attention
to you because of Call of Duty
I'm kind of a beast at that game
dropping 30s on the reg pew pew
laughs
that's pretty funny right that's pretty
good
drop in 30s on the reg pew pew
and she won't pay attention to me
oh okay
excellent
I like the new con I think it's good
um I think it could be better but it's
definitely one of the best cods that
have come out
in a while
okay so we need
10 strength
man we still have to beat Reichard to
get that huh
chat approved
my girlfriend hates video games of the
passion man
I dated a girl for six years that didn't
like
didn't like games
it didn't work out
I also dated a girl who did like games
and that didn't work out either
uh I think I'm gonna die alone
I think that's what's gonna happen that
that's okay though
I'm okay
hopefully that doesn't happen
if it does
I need to beat up about it
need a girl who likes Elden ring lore
um
good thing you have 102 000 Subs
do you guys think that being an online
influencer helps you in the dating world
I'm curious of what y'all think of that
girls like money
hmm
no no no no
hmm
depends if the chick is an Instagram
model
what
why would that have an effect
girls like money guys I don't think
that's a good argument because everyone
likes money Everyone likes
to feel comfortable
in the relationship that they're in
right which I think includes money
like if you're you know you always want
the girl that'll struggle with you
obviously
and you you know like the girl wants the
same like if if a guy's struggling and
they're struggling too like
I don't know I don't think we're in a
world that like the man has to only
provide for the girl I think everyone
likes money everyone wants to work hard
and feel a sense of purpose in life
um
you know those days are long past but I
think it took like if you know you're
not doing anything you're not making any
money you're not like doing anything
with your life that's got to be some of
the most that has to be one of the most
unattractive things on a girl or a boy
so if they're not like making money
that's just kind of a part of that right
so that that argument's weird like
saying like girls like money Everyone
likes money man it just makes stuff
easier better blah blah blah
I think if you have a passion the money
won't matter as much to the person
you're with
whoa
boy or girl
foreign
guys is the stamina Talisman good for uh
sorcerer builds as well
I think it's good no matter what
not really
gotcha
I cannot my stamina a bit at some point
I mean yeah I mean the turtle talisman
[Music]
I'm always gonna let this cutscene play
every time
every time
[Music]
no very well
we will devour
the very gods
together
that's trippy
damn it
you're like two seconds off there drips
three seconds man I give it to random
streamers thank you for the two dollars
man I appreciate it
thank you bro
very close
he backed up
oh God
as long as he's not doing that crazy
attack
we're doing okay uh oh wrong thing wrong
thing
remember what I said about the crazy
attack here it comes
time to run boys
this OST is so good though
Here Comes
okay we're good
look good feel good play good
what a trickster man
there we go
oh that almost killed me
nice
reichardt's so easy now
right right guys a serpent Never Dies
foreign
if you come back later with spiral
shards I will show you how absurdly
powerful Sorcerers are
spiral shards oh the blue things
I think I get what you mean by that
I think I get it I think I get it okay
get that to 50. get that to yep yep yep
let's pump that right
hell yeah
one pop Trump thanks for coming to Elden
Lord dude hopefully that comes up on
screen ah geez what to say uh first of
all I'd like to thank my reformed
Orthodox Rabbi Bill Clinton
thank you Trump I don't know why I
didn't come up on screen tanith is
eating Reichard
all is well with the world guys
all is well with the world okay let's
replace
this
with Comet you guys said comet's good
see what it looks like
okay okay
and now we can use the shield as well
but we want to put carrying retaliation
on it so let's go do that
Corian
comments to spell Gideon loves a Spam
did I start upping my decks
so that I can
I just thought of that too
I need to listen to Hugo
me forgiveness
road is yet long a God is not easily
failed
become Goku you will have your wish you
want common dessert
I didn't I'll be doing well just lay out
you could plan on completing the run
today I plan on streaming until around 3
30 4 o'clock
so take that as you will see how far we
get doing that
so Ash of War on here current
retaliation Magic
uh
[Music]
and then strengthen
ithing Stone two
stay
Ed's coming along guys
waiting for malachath and Melania
of course
what's new with me man
those are uh My Kryptonite to be honest
with you oh I don't have anything
I think we'll be okay so far
never know why the circuit representing
Gideon was in there
probably just a spy who got eaten
you know
oh and since you're doing sorcery you
should do selins quest for the Primeval
sorceries
not for that but for The Shard spiral
okay
um
I already found her
he's over here right
she's in here
if if I remember correctly
for sure
hold on
everybody hold
texting
there we go
that's a step of the quests the shop is
in Lim grave well let's do the quest
anyway I haven't done it since we did
the 100 run
which was super freaking awesome
I wish I could erase all my memory and
do the 100 run again
that was definitely the best streams
I've ever done
it was so much fun
everybody hold
everybody hold
hello
how'd the date go it will do no good
by something degenerates
[Music]
I can't get out
break man
dang that's strong
out of the cancellation go there you go
thank you
[Music]
all right now they got now they got [ __ ]
all up in what did she say
okay what do I need I don't remember
they're not gonna stop asking I'm
surprised you guys got all all about
that that's very it's very nice
all right
what do I need to get again you need to
find a new body for her right she's
already got a new body well I have to
yeah yeah
you have to talk to Mr lusat in Mount
glemier then get the second stage
that
is this worth it Chad
is this worth
right azure
he is somewhere over here
let me go let me go here and then we'll
we'll go up that way
you take you get a ton of good spells
all right we should do it then
let me put this back down
too bright
there's a lot of Windows in here you
guys see that this window right here
runs all the way to the end of the wall
so it's a huge window and whenever Joy's
here I'm gonna put her bed right here
and then she likes to put her head on
the window still right here we had her
over yesterday but we didn't have her
stuff so my parents took her back home
just for one more day because they
wanted to be with her for one more day
um window right there and then a window
back there and then a big porch
big porch that Joy likes
we got a couch out there for her and
everything
so it gets very bright in here I'll have
to figure out all the all the lighting
remember to get sorcery Scrolls
yeah
I gotta remember those
you gotta remember where those are
cool lamp thanks man it's a lamp
foreign
once the couch gets here
that'll be big
since she canceled the date and money
don't matter she pays for the next eat
out date
I agree press one in chat if uh if she
should pay for the date
everybody press one
big porch for joy
shrew dude shrew
true
yeah I'll probably pay for the date it's
okay
I agree though
what do you guys think do you guys agree
that like the guy should always pay for
the date
what's your opinion on that
[Music]
foreign
that shouldn't be a thing
split the bill
I've had girls get mad at me for one
saying that
not even on the first date
I always pay for the first date every
time I don't think I've ever not paid
for the first date
but I have had dates where you know
just throw it out there split the bill
it'd be like a
you know fifth sixth date or something
right
I'll say like you want to split it and
she'll like get but like she'll go
really
I'll go okay
and then I stopped dating that girl
and then I don't talk to her anymore
when she responds like that
it's weird
[Music]
I think every once in a while it should
be okay
yeah any girl that gets mad at that not
the one
at least for me
if it's always dates that cost money
then no but also come up with more
creative dates than dinner in a movie
walks in the park hiking bike ride that
is true
that's true but that's that's different
that's not the same date
I'm we're talking about dates that cost
money
where you go out to dinner or go to a
movie or something that costs
moolah
first date she said she was paying had
no chance to respond there you go
nice
I think it just depends
Jake's upcoming date take notes nah I
mean money is not a big deal
it it's to me money isn't a big deal
I like money I like having money you
need money
but
I don't know
I think basing your life on the amount
of money you earn is not a great
lifestyle for me
I think we already have the Academy's
roll Kirby
trying to remember
hmm
it's not up here
how does anyone get mad at splitting
it's literally just fair
it's if they get mad
Maybe
if they were like
I don't know how to put it
maybe if it was like uh
if she said oh I'm sorry do you do you
mind getting this one I don't care
that's fine
I just I couldn't date a girl that is
only that doesn't work
who doesn't have uh
something to go for
you know
I don't think I could uh personally do
that do that
yes right this way right right this way
it's through that one place you meet
Alexander that's right I don't remember
how to get over there though I'm just
trying to get all the um
The Graces to go to
money for Living not living for money
that's that's kind of where I'm at
you've accessed a great Glenstone and
Shard Swift Glenstone shard
uh you have this roll
uh
I swear a chat made me get that before
I can't remember
I simply do not remember
okay
now I should get the uh
the golden seed over here
over there
damn pretty scene
I'm not fighting that Beast
hell no
[ __ ] that boss
exactly Alexander
that's just me though like if uh
some people aren't like that
oh boy
you know what F you bro
dang this is strong
wow
okay let me get the map
as well
I think it's just Elden green Elden ring
Graphics mod I think that's that's it
pretty sure anyway
it makes the game look really freaking
good
God damn it torrent
really
torrent staggers
so easily
I'll shoot
okay
is there a seed down there too
no there's just a bonfire
I just remembered a crystal tear
there's a tear that lets you complete
completely negate magic is that for
killing this guy
this boss down here
oh
I hate fighting these things
but let's do it
that's the no FP one isn't that always
it's been
okay bro
let's do it
I'm gonna get off torrent
these things are so dumb foreign
oh God
[Music]
bye bye
nice
[ __ ] I miss you
is you both famous now
in our [ __ ] stream
thank you for the five Trump I
appreciate it man
Yubel is gone when we needed him the
most we never needed him chat
he was an annoying troll
who made multiple accounts to do so
free FP for 15 seconds
okay that seems kind of lit
there we go
ahead and throw that one on huh
causes oh yeah
that's fine it was never the same after
he left
okay
how do I get over to Alexander again
he's like over here right
wait I think
wait I can literally go down here I
think hold on
oh God
evil is the primary antagonist of the
dimension World Arc of Yu-Gi-Oh GX anime
available monster whose card was in
Jaden Yuki's possession when he was a
child evil was previously obese
are you guys making up lore for yuble
stop it
please stop
[Music]
was around when I was fighting malacat
for the challenge
what
the heck's out here man
oh my God Anastasia
foreign
she's a god
why am I'm scared of her just because of
the challenge we did
I have no reason
no reason to be scared of her
in during the challenge she just
absolutely annihilated me so many times
that I'm scared of her now
evil could have beat her chat why did
you like you bull
also you didn't we actively voted to ban
him and then when he made new accounts
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
that's a photo oh my God that looks so
good right there
um
and when he made new accounts you guys
were like that's you will bantam
I didn't even do that you guys did
what's up Keanu
combine that with meteorite later meteor
of acyl and you will crush almost
anything there's different meteorites
oh yeah I know what you're talking about
I know what you're talking about
rip
we didn't know what we were doing
uh you
you poor heads
foreign
just keep swinging
just keep swinging
see what happens
dead
it's different
you guys are a bunch of foreheads you
know that
you are
you know why because I bet some of you
haven't liked the stream yet
couldn't be me dude
yeah you guys need to like the stream I
don't know what y'all are doing you know
like in the Stream
not doing it
kinda crazy man
stop exposing me
I did dragon I just exposed you
I have no emotional attachment to you
will neither do I
but somehow chat does
this is how we get to Alexander guys
or that kind of area that he's in
is it up there and then left
drawing a blank
yeah I don't remember how to get to the
magma worm I I think I do have to go up
up and left
right
didn't I go up the slider
exactly trips
our entry viewing side of Grace
you died
whoa A lot of people just died what the
heck
why don't people play a new game plus
they do
they they do do that
huh you said dude
is it this way
no
forget what somber this is if it's even
a somber
it's good to know actually
I'm gonna leave that wolf alone
there's a secret invisible Bridge
totally
oh my God really
just eat off the bridge
Chad I was here
I go this way
this is to something else
[Music]
oh
I gotta get over there
how do I do this
pain
from Ulta split though you should start
running toward Mount glomer's Spyro
counterclockwise short after the fort
you will find magna worm and Alexander
I'm dyslexic though and can't read
so even though I read that correctly
I don't understand it
that's the issue
let me reset let me reset
let me calm down
okay I'm lost now too
all right so this is First Mount blemere
site
you said ER tree Grazing Hill
do I not have that Grace yet
it's over here
right
all right
so it's not even close to where I am wow
all right
lighting changed hold
yeah I have not done anything with
patches bro
all right going over here
going over here Yonder
going over here Yonder
okay Eldon Joe there's so many things in
this game to remember I can't remember
all of them and neither can anybody else
all right
all right
now you shut your [ __ ] mouth
good
[Laughter]
you shut your [ __ ] mouth right now
you totally remember everything wow
that's great good for you bro oh my God
if you had to see a Millicent's thing
okay where am I going again
I should remember at this point
I go like up there
before I go back
go up the slope
I'm going up the slope
do the bird thing no that only comes
when you like the Stream
[Music]
boo
bad boss bad boss
actually are kind of cool
thank you
oh [ __ ]
you all know what's gonna happen
what's hurting me man
okay wait watch this
literally owned
nice
I'm fighting [ __ ] walnir
from DS3
there we go
Chase
okay
I got distracted now where
I keep going
continuing
oh I remember this area this area is
weird
is there a church near here I mean that
is a church but
oh I know where to go
I remember now
I do I do I do
yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
foreign
it clicked in my brain
have you killed godskin Duo
today no
another seed
they are fun if you take them seriously
they look really cool like the the tibia
Mariners are actually really cool
looking
but you know what I mean you know what I
mean
you know what I'm saying
am I going the right way
where does this go
I feel like I just haven't been in this
area that much
oh I remember this place
dude I've been here like once
this game is so freaking big
left of the castle Yeah
I'm on the right path lit let's go
buy your scorpion
do we want that
probably not
right
I don't think that'll be extremely
helpful for us
oh God
I hate this boss chat
[Music]
I think they're dumb
get off
that is not the slicer
it hates you too probably man
damn
you are creepy man where are you going
suck my
foot
oh what
I [ __ ] up
currently [ __ ] up quite a bit
what is that
what is that man
oh
I've never seen it do that thrust attack
before either man
I have quite literally never seen that
before
oh my God I despise this boss man
thank you
okay
sure
sure man
I might just slice him up boys
not actually
no no
I see
get off the horse
dude this thing is a beast
I'm gonna pepper its head
yep
yep
oh [ __ ]
first time ever seeing it do that attack
ever
well second time technically but he's
done it twice in a row now
what a hit
GG
oh
what an annoying person
I don't think Alexander is gonna be over
here
he is here
hey man
ah I hardly think meteorite and then use
your physics
thank you
do it
perhaps Al has an old above the law
okay
um is communism this way
actually I think I hit a dead end over
here dummy
maybe not
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it is this way
it do be this way
yeah yeah
okay
first try zero deaths as per usual here
huh where's this bear
the strongest enemy in the game by far
I need to run
nope
nope
nope
foreign
can a bear do that
that's a dragon attack
this game man
the Bears have Dragon Eyes
that I don't know I have not looked at
it
that closely
oh yeah these two are having like a
conference or whatever
okay I'll I'll go [ __ ] myself wow
I actually just got bullied
Rune bears are bears that ate a dragon
heart
really
that's pretty cool
okay that's good
what the f
uck
foreign
at least there is a stake of America
here oh my God
this could be the worst gank in the game
right here bro
at 20 20K don't mean that much to us to
be honest
20K isn't even a level
hey you guys said there's a Grace
there it be
I think coming from the angle that I was
at
it was just like ridiculous
the direction I mean
yo this looks awesome like this
I've always thought this boss looked
like a bloodborne boss yeah
dude I need to not have this many
spells
oh yeah physic
foreign
she doesn't respawn does she
a memory
did they all die after she dies
hello sir
such a cool design
there it is guys
omits azur
oh I forgot to retaliate that entire
time too
I got I gotta get into the into the boss
or into the
you know what I mean into my character
look at this boss design though or this
this guy's design
so cool
time for Kamehameha
Kamehameha Kamehameha
I don't really like the great bow
I'm not huge on this either
I'll take it off and then we're gonna
use
60 inch
holy [ __ ] dick
holy [ __ ]
wow 60 inch
what are we at
58 so we're actually close
all right
um well we have that so
um
yo drips
thanks for coming to tarnish brother
all right let me reload this stuff
because it's not working
at least those aren't
um I appreciate it man have fun at your
movie I don't know what movie you're
seeing but hope it's a good one
and Millennia will be fine right guys
likes it to sellin the normal Selen or
the underground selling
they're both Underground
you know what I mean
baby one drips
yeah 60s minimum anyway my Apprentice
shall we commence the left
show is there a sorcery
tell me your story
call I was exiled from this for attempt
we know we know all this we're we're
trying to get stuff
let us journey together
my Apprentice with this glimstone key
to restore the Primeval current of keys
nigh a child of
I need to give this to lusat
and he's the one in caled right
where we already uh found him we're
already kind of there
yeah yeah
in this cave
secret cave
I don't have a speculation on Glenstone
rotten Crystal Trio oh God
is that what's in here
[Music]
nice
right I don't I've already been here as
well
what does that mean
no
don't have a lantern by the way
there's not some wizard spell that I can
cast right now that'll give me some
light
what happened here
huh I could have just done this
wait it's not
in the exact what the frick that's kind
of weird
interesting
oh whoa whoa you guys are going crazy
whoa whoa whoa
I already have I just got it Archie's
like a minute ago
annoying
y'all suck
I didn't mean it
oh okay
statue of America
wait is that where this boss is
oh God
foreign
I am going down
what the
I don't have a lantern man
should I just fight the boss
I went too far okay well then I might as
well fight the boss
since I'm here
I'm regretting my decision
foreign
okay there we go
oh my God
thank you
get over here
I don't have stamina
okay gee not leaving
I mean I can't really [ __ ]
foreign
there we go
I need to stop holding it down
wow
wow
okay
jump down where
thought I did like I'm I'm literally
going down constantly
since the boss again
I'm trying one more time
that's probably dumb to do huh
I still need stamina to cast spells
so I feel like the stamina thing would
actually be helpful
well not really
okay that attack is terrifying
okay
foreign
this is not uh the most enjoyable boss
in the world
I will say
foreign
[Music]
doing my best
can I not
you know
whatever
okay
I'm trying to strafe that [ __ ] attack
oh wait soon I'm not gonna be able to
attack
oh that's bad
okay uh we're gonna have to use this
no I have to use this
oh this is not good
oh no
shoot
are you kidding me
like I did that pretty
I did that pretty quick too man
that's insanely unlucky it's like it
input it it knew my input of going to
the menu
okay you guys want me to go back here
there's some [ __ ] I don't know [ __ ]
that boss
[ __ ] that boss man
I'm not
hmm
down here huh
yo dude it's a wizard
a dead wizard
Salient seal breaker
used
it's him
stars of ruin
is that good
oh God I can't leave
stop it
the blue balls guy
no
foreign
why did we do that chat
super does that progress selins
questline
yeah okay
hmm
how
I'm lost and I can't leave
I don't have that many runes I could
just leave
like this
yup [ __ ] it
I don't want to be in that cave anymore
I don't like it
I don't like it
okay I'm gonna assume
up is out
there we go
you should upgrade your staff I don't
think this staff is upgradable right
uh whenever I feel like it Archies
whenever I freaking feel like it chat
okay
then Dark Souls 2 will come back also
have you guys liked the stream yet
if you haven't liked the stream yet I
don't know what you're doing but you
need to you need to kick it into gear
and like the stream okay
thanks guys
thanks guys we actually have more likes
than viewers so we're good
we literally have more likes than
viewers so we're fine all right
yeah I'm using meteorite staff
okay back to selling
we play Hogwarts Legacy
probably my Apprentice
give me a moment later I have a favor
the form you see before you is merely my
body my body in prison can you make that
I have something
who could have guessed you have my grad
I am truly this is a
okay
only okay
you wish tours indeed
wait okay I already got that
okay now
down
here
will you perhaps tell me a vague timing
I just did that was that's as vague as I
can get
whenever I feel like it
that's the only answer I have for you
man
yeah we killed Ronaldo like a
long time ago not today
I stream a lot man I really do my
Apprentice
thank you for
you [ __ ] shackles take a toll on us all
there is something I need my Primal star
has fallen and my someone may come for
my life myself
oh oh yeah I remember doesn't she like
yeah this is
[Music]
that looks painful
selins primal glintstone
this
is my
this is my Essence do I take it back to
yayi dab
once we uh finish this playthrough chat
I want to learn I really really want to
start learning the oh she's gone I
really want to start learning the speed
run that's kind of like the next thing I
want to do
I already did activate my equipment huh
solve this seller
so I go to sell this
is that over here
the spot
secret puppet chamber where's that
it's gonna be glitchless Alexander
yeah it's still serious yeah okay
it's at one of the ruins okay
between the Rises
in the weeds
oh
ah
I don't think
a description of where I need to go will
be helpful here
chilly mist
could be good
I see what y'all are saying
oh you're late okay
excellent
ah yes indeed
this is so [ __ ] weird
let me solo her
what did they do to you
no
all right do not touch
what a freak
my Apprentice
just how long has it been
thank you
you've helped me fill a new body once
again
a snug fit for my Primal Glenstone
better still I've shed those awful
shackles
finally I can return to the academy
to expel the car God angel
finally I can return to this to expel
the Korean royal family oh so now is she
gonna be at rinalda's Chambers or right
outside of it
do I go talk to jarin
as well
you should have used the doll okay
so will she be outside of um the doors
here now
help her more or help Jaren
should I go talk to him
you might as well right here
right here
yeah it's the summon signs outside right
oh we got this boss
see I know this boss because uh it's
where I get my ruined great sword my
favorite weapon in the whole game
wow man
okay
okay
this sucks
oh get give me a break okay
look
okay hold
no I didn't put on common azure
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
Oh I thought I was out of reach
they never give you an inch
[Music]
we're gonna go with the slice them up
we're gonna slice them
whew
okay
oh yeah I still need two more in it too
good point
no oh
dude incorporating the tail into this
fight it's so awkward and maybe we don't
slice them
maybe we don't slice them boys get out
of that animation Jesus
I'm trying like I've been rolling around
the entire time and I still haven't
broken everything
there we go
yeah I know you don't have to talk to
jarin thought we would and then ask chat
what we want to do
that sound more fun
I'm literally out of stuff where are you
is it usually in here
runes Greatsword is ugly that's a bad
opinion
isn't usually here chat
using sell and sell
even before I talk to him
I have to reset the area
I think you're right
I've already killed radon
oh I see I didn't know this popped up
here
we're done head is dead as hell
has nothing to do with the questline
so curious
hmm
okay I guess he's at the cellar now
here
hit [ __ ] excuse me Chad
well
not here yet
oh chain selling
Jesus
like how can how is it possible to
remember all these details
I understand like first time through
listening to the quest line knowing
where to go
all right
uh do you mean the one up here
foreign
podcast
no thanks yeah I might just do the fight
at this point
you missed him
no
all right [ __ ] it whatever
foreign
my sweet teens
so fresh and your
all right well we still have the option
examine
be summoned to challenge sorceress
selling be summoned to assist what do
you guys want to do
I don't really care
help
help help assist kill no spell
help help help help okay okay okay we're
gonna do that
I will help
not right now
for a
[Music]
why don't you say join the school
seems off
doesn't it
damn he's getting cooked right now
he is rolling like a [ __ ]
where does Ronaldo go
is she just like did she just walk away
like where where is she
foreign
all right
John's dead
she up there
he goes in the corner
I don't think so
is she actually in a corner
he actually does I didn't know that
of the dock be not a fear wow my beloved
egg that's grippy
come out I pray thee
cool
wow I thou now assured of thy want to
born a meal all different dialogue
you notice the different dialogue
same thing
this is the same I would birth
well it's the same dialogue but she said
it different
[ __ ] wow cool detail did not know that
do you guys know that
some of you did I did not
cool ah my Apprentice you sure you've
saved my skin once again
do you see this the queen of carrier is
no more
with the bodies of Masters Azure and you
sat returned the academy can hone the
Primeval current
so that we Fallen Children of the Stars
shall Beam with Brilliance once again so
is she tripping her will you stay with
us here at the Academy
oh
I know it's not possible you have your
own calling
to be the next Elden lord it's real but
do think of me of your teacher
on the eve of your crowning you will
always be my darling pupil rest assured
she's just saying that out loud with her
right over there the entire
Square allegiance to the new monarch my
Apprentice
become Elden Lord
okay
but here is a symbol of my allegiance
and the Academies
that looks cool do you recall what once
I told you
that Glenstone is the Amber of the
cosmos and yeah selling's really good
looking under the mask by the way you
guys didn't seize all these video on
that a long time ago would you please
Illuminate Me
lay bare the secrets of life it's [ __ ]
of course it is
time
I will be your student
interesting
so Ronaldo
just capture right here right
I mean just bodies the [ __ ] out of her
yeah
to look like this
there we go I got a crown
hahaha
my
oh
I
is is that what is that what we know to
be
like do we know if that was Ronaldo
who did this
wow
now assured of thy want to be born anew
not behind the balls
she did it herself
granola did
be not alarmed
by Angel
I mean I would imagine she's a sick of
her BS yeah
because she said uh
you know the queen is is no more
and then
I think the queen is fine
she's just distracted
this is what happens when people mess
with the Primal energies of the lands
between do we know that though like is
that a is that fact have we seen that
before or are we just theorizing there
theorizing is great but I'm just curious
if it's like no that's
that's it that's what it is
it's facts
so how did she mess with it by trying to
be the new
Queen
idolians and guinea pig Hazel I
she's nowhere near as insane as everyone
thinks she is
I believe she dabbled too much in the
Primeval currents
Graven Mass talisman
she took out her Primal glintstone and
transported it right I mean we gave it
to her
um
so what you're saying is chat is that
she [ __ ] around and she found out
is that what you're saying
yeah
she [ __ ] around and found out
sounds fair
all right good now
I think we need to continue our
West here
let's see how we're doing against uh
good old morgot
it's worth three hours in we have barely
done any main bosses today
have we done any while we beat Reichard
by the Spells I just want to get 52 in
that's my goal right now
but I shall
why do I want the spiral spell so bad
the one where it goes
do you like Dark Souls 3 bosses yes I
did
you're at walnir
okay you're not even remotely close to
done keep going
here is the worst boss in the game one
of the worst don't even think of woolner
he's all right he's a gimmick
it tunnels through big bosses well
morgot's not very big
I'll get it before right after this I
just want to get 52 in
that's my goal 52 int
I ain't [ __ ] around with that
assassin
[Music]
oh
[Music]
Chad are you kidding me
Chad
chat
and this shall not be forgiven
okay so I am now fully understanding
why some people said morgot was easy
what level am I
76.
that's right on
what the [ __ ] was that
so
okay
that was a joke
I I feel bad
wow
all right
old friend dude I always wondered like
I'd get comments all the time like dude
more got so easy I'm like dude I
struggled them so hard with bloodhound's
Fang first playthrough by the mantle of
bugs
are impenetrable a husk of the earth
trees being incredible
I struggle with them like crazy man
stand before the Eldon ring
come the Elder Lord
is to pass the thorns my purpose
in that very Act so I'd like you to
undertake a New Journey I mean we have
30 Vigor with me and 50 in the flame of
ruin
and then
brain over muscles facts dude
I like listening to Melanie I think
she's cool
dude that I put it on I put that short
on Tick Tock as well chat and it's
popping off on Tick Tock bro
that's funny
popping off for me anyway
radigan's gonna be fun
okay
hmm
shall I turn let my help share them with
me
your thoughts
wait I already had 50 in the principal
or 52.
[ __ ] I didn't need to do that
me Bob that up a bit
and maybe that for now
and then we'll probably just go full in
on uh int for the rest of the game
okay you guys wanted me to get what
the spinny spin
no it was 60 you're right bro
my brain oh [ __ ]
okay
that's my bad that's my bad I forgot
damn
well we'll get there eventually
what'd you guys want me to get
guard spiral fires twin spiraling
projectiles this one
really
you guys are sure
like this is good
apparently
is this what you're talking about or was
it this one Crystal barrage no you said
Shard spiral right
yep
all right
obtained
obtained
yeah reichard's Dead uh let's keep going
then
all right
I think next is fire Giant
oh
Brian piercer
I wish you could use torrent through
this whole area
but we are in the city it makes sense
not to be able to use them
[ __ ] the fire Giant
that's what I'm saying bro
oh it's fun for PVP
I found that I am
I am just not a PVP or in this game
however I do see myself if they make a
Boss Rush in the coliseums I could see
myself getting really into that though
I can see myself getting really into
that
I love boss rushes I did it for sakiro
many many times
I never I don't think I ever finished
some of them though
correct I would only level Vigor
struggle we have to get to 500 Members
First
we are currently at 314.
so that's pretty far off
that was the bee's knees it was fun I
had a good time
you're right
you right
no I I tried Destiny and Destiny 2 and
I'm just not a giant fan of those games
personally
really wonder if there's a legitimate
reason why torrent can only be used
on Ronnie's karian Divine Tower
isn't that interesting
I find that to be interesting
really
favorite Assassin's Creed Brotherhood
easy answer
Brotherhood
yeah piss off buddy
Brotherhood was fire
it's okay I struggle
I got you
I feel like we're pretty dang strong
right now
Alexander Morgan's great room yeah
I don't think great runes are really
that great like they don't really matter
that much
to be honest with you
foreign
[Music]
so I'm going to get joy tonight from my
parents house chat
and they want me to pick up dinner what
should we get
and here's the thing
can't be fast food
now it can be stuff like I get like I
don't consider Chinese
or pizza to be fast food
fast food I think of like McDonald's
Taco Bell Wendy's
but I was gonna pick up dinner
and then we're gonna have dinner and
then Joy's gonna come back here with me
so for tomorrow's stream
you will likely see a lot of joy
it's just me and her gonna be here now
get a pizza
we had pizza last time
I'm not gonna lie Joy's probably gonna
be right here because I'm gonna put her
bed right here and then she's gonna look
out the window she'll sit up and put her
head on right here and look out the
window
32 bigger moment uh yep
yep
Oh I thought I got off
well rip all the runes I had
this game is so funny
do I even need to kill this guy
why is my jump off just not working
foreign
holy [ __ ]
I can't see
please
no
holy [ __ ]
foreign
you can run by
I know that
but I want to kill him
damn man
I I thought I dodged I probably didn't
have stamina stamina is a little bit
harder to manage when you're a wizard
build because you do use stamina bite
I guess it's the same
but you get what I mean
bro
okay I guess that just goes for forever
thank you
[ __ ]
this is so strong
dude it runs through FP though
hmm
is Rock sling even good
um
I'm thinking of running pass what do you
guys think
okay every time scrim talks in the chat
he retracts his message
why
foreign
yeah well I don't have comment yet
well I do
I think you mean common dessert
equip Azure offhand
this
all right [ __ ] it we're trying it
that looks like the same
can I have stamina again pain
dang it
oh my God
these guys are so annoying to fight
bruh
what
he's a gargoyle
there we go
upgrade your staff you can't upgrade
this staff
or you probably mean the other one
the meteoric staff you cannot upgrade
we probably mean the other one
the offhand one
would that does that really increase it
like did it actually increase it right
there
leveling it
these are one dog
is it a somber one
oh my God I'm so stupid
upgrading the Azure one won't help
but having in the offhand did it
actually help or no because it seemed
like the same
yeah should I should I move over to
Ronaldo's
staff
I have to go get it but should I use
that
because we said meteoritic staff is like
the best uh early game right
not renal is Lou sets
okay where's his
I feel like I should use Ronaldo's stuff
we go uh
here
it's in Celia
is it those two little
those two [ __ ]
the mini boss there
I'll go there
we'll compare
I'll go there
uh that is Celia Celia Celia
Australia
uh
dude kidding me
I'll go down from there
saves costs on FP you guys seem to have
a lot of opinions on the staffs here
I'm seeing a lot of opinions
that are different from each other
flying around
I don't know how to feel about it
I don't know how to feel about it man
I'll live here yeah
this totally won't kill me randomly huh
okay we're good
got the statue America though
foreign
staff
dude I need those man [ __ ] whatever
wait don't I have to hit every door lock
or something oh my God this is I'm going
back no I don't care I'm gonna use
Ronaldo's thing
I don't care if it's worse or better or
whatever I'm gonna use it
I don't want to do all this
I'm going in here
going to get Ronaldo's
I'm over it
over it chat
over it
I do okay
over it
oh man
it's good enough
uh this
wait I use your soul
[ __ ] dude did I
I was disappointed that Elden ring is as
vibrant and colorful as it is I was
expecting something gray and dark like
Dark Souls
that's an opinion
I already used this man can I use it
again
probably not
I don't remember what we did on this
damn character [ __ ] uh
where's a where's another normal one I'm
I'm blinking uh
there's one in the the lake here
that one's kind of annoying though
uh
this one's so annoying though
so I guess it's not that bad
well now I have runes
I get lost here every time
yeah I think this is the only other one
isn't there
isn't it
it's this way
let's not type the alphabet X
why
why
fire cheese
you didn't like uh what we said about
his opinion on the game being too
colorful
no Ding Dongs no demigod remembrance
is ranala a demigod
technically no
I don't think she's a demigod
how much have we done
[ __ ] man we already did it
all right well I guess we gotta go this
way
Renault is a step demigod that's not how
that works
nope
did I not
hit the God Bless America chat
God Bless America
bless it all
I don't know you just you just can't
you simply just cannot upgrade the
meteoric staff
foreign
[Music]
yeah meteoric staff is good for the the
early game
why should God just bless one country
why specifically America I don't [ __ ]
know dude that's what was ingrained in
my brain in American schools
I had to stand up like a [ __ ] robot
and put my hand over my heart and
start the day every day like that
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God which they've taken out by the
way indivisible with liberty and justice
for all
every day
[ __ ] weird
dude I don't even like America chat I'm
trying to move to Norway by at the time
I'm 32.
like a life goal of mine live in Norway
by 32.
what
America's Britain with guns
well doesn't uh
doesn't Britain have a problem with
knives or something I don't remember
foreign
I think that's London actually
no this is not a new game
America is Britain with debt
they do got dead we do have debt here
it's not as half as bad with the US with
guns oh I agree
I don't want to get in a gun debate with
you guys at all
so let's not
Elden ring lore happenings
what do you mean
uh
the United States is the Florida of the
world
to to all people who are not from the US
in chat
is is America like a meme to the rest of
to to you
can go fishing without having a license
depends on the type of fishing you do
it's a meme
what what about it is the meme
everything
where did it hit meme level for you
all of it
right
everything
come on it can't be everything
why specifically Norway uh
a lot of reasons
a lot of reasons I still need to visit
Europe and then probably make a better
decision on that but
Norway is my number one choice right now
here's where I'm at
here here's my main reason
I would like to have kids chat
I think I'd be a cool dad
I really do
however
I don't want to raise a kid here
for many reasons
does that make sense
a lot of people are choosing not to have
kids in America right now
AGT Daddy I was looking at Chad I went
the wrong way wait what
was it just facing a weird Direction
here
facing this way
maybe it always has and I'm just stupid
yeah
I'm just a little dumb
yep
that's just where that's my biggest
reason man I don't want to raise a kid
in America I just don't want to
I uh don't think it would be the best
place uh probably anywhere in the
country
currently
to uh to do so
so yeah
yeah a lot of people are choosing not to
be in relationships I've been close with
that
Taryn I'm not gonna lie I have I have
actually been close to choosing that
route to just like not
have kids and not be in a relationship
at all or at least never get married
I've been close with that
haven't decided fully on anything yet
but
you know
it's a tough call
it's a very very tough call
receive equipment uh
hour of remembrance
Karen Regal scepter bada bing bada boom
chat bada bing bada boom right there
boom
you know what I'm saying
maybe overpopulation was okay
no I think it's sorting itself out like
Yeah by uh us just not having kids
as much as we used to
kids used to come out of the [ __ ]
woodwork man now it's just like eh
sounds mid how much oh I need 60 in to
even use this huh
and I need a somber one
what kind of stuff am I working with
here
I have a two I need a three four
five six need a seven
okay we're gonna make this work for now
yep
just level int
I'll go to EG
ypt
I'm gonna level it once
and then
go to our boy hopefully have enough
actually
nah I'm not gonna use a larva too we'll
get there
you know you know what uh no never mind
never mind
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay uh there's
our one
I needed a three right [ __ ] okay I only
need a few more
let me go get some
how much do you give 52 not enough
uh where can I get 500 runes really fast
127.
okay and then one of these dudes
excellent
yeah there was a boss a little bit
further behind me there yeah
and then now we're just getting to 60
int
I'd just rather not fight that Boss by
the way
um let's see
let's let's just beat this guy real
quick
I think we can
re-equip The Shield then you only need
one inch
what did The Shield have to do with that
wait does the shield raise intelligence
is that what you're saying
I didn't look I should have looked
you don't like Nile
he's kind of [ __ ] annoying
it's a cool fight though
I don't know how I'm gonna do against
him as a sorcerer
I've kind of got him figured out as a uh
you know normal sword type of guy
get out of my way sir
I can't figure out the timing there we
go
excellent
excellent
light malakis I will when I get there my
guy I am not there yet currently
so uh you know
tighten up those panties man and uh calm
down
hmm
oh boy
foreign
that [ __ ] guy
is so annoying you have 60 in
I do
oh
no clue TJ
okay you guys want me to use this
and
I can't use commissary now uh
it's Terror magical really that worth it
when you slicer I want to use Comet
guard spiral
is Rock sling not gonna be that great
anymore
we'll make some changes we'll make some
changes
changes
I'm curious what this is
what the [ __ ]
isn't that crazy
you Demon Souls after Elden ring is a
big switch
I still need to go and finish Demon
Souls
God I hate dodging this guy
there we go
this is the only way I know how to get
through here
I know I could go over here and hit the
elevator
it was very close already
go through the gate to the wood stairs
yeah I always like I go that way when
you guys say that and it's just not
there I don't I don't know
why that is
all right I don't know
it's pretty rare that it actually
happens but
you know what I mean
okay
this will be fine for now there
no [ __ ] the grace
that's super cool
I love that for me
holy [ __ ]
don't worry
it was already 15 seconds damn
this [ __ ] does not hurt him at all
[Music]
right yep
foreign
okay well there's that
no way that reached me
nope
I thought I already drank the blue flask
so I switched them whatever
that was annoying I thought I already
[ __ ] cast it man I just it just
didn't or not cast but use one of the
flasks that I wanted to use and I
pressed the button and it just didn't
happen
Chad we can we get a round of applause
for OBS telling me that I've dropped 43
000 frames today
claps in the chat for that I don't know
what the [ __ ] going on some of you
guys are like it's dropping frames and
then some of you guys are like it's
totally fine I don't know I can't tell
at this point
I'll have to make some adjustments
usually we drop zero frames
consistently zero
but we're at the new place
and [ __ ] happens
oh I forgot this dude
turn
you didn't turn I [ __ ] up
definitely messed up here chat
foreign
how is that reaching me randomly
he said that was for big dudes
I don't know if I consider him a big
dude
I'm out of Mana
which is not good
what do I do now
uh
I could have been using hers the entire
time I'm a dumbass
probably die here oh yeah we're dead
Here We Go Again boys
or I try to beat him up with this
foreign
[Music]
let's just go again
a few milliseconds of delay some drop
frames but not annoying well I don't
want any of that stuff
I don't want none of it I want zero drop
frames consistently the entire time
because I'm a freak
okay let's try using our staff well
actually I don't want to use your staff
because we haven't upgraded it at all
yet
let's do this
um
yeah
let me change these up
is it like that girl like actually
let's do a big six banger
yeah it seems like common dessert really
is not that great
we don't we don't need that Rob
yeah I'll wait on the physic
uh until I killed the two doodads
I'll just comment those idiots
[ __ ] frost spots
how about your mom uses my frostbots
huh
I'm gonna pepper him though
I really thought he would stagger oh my
God
really thought he would stagger there
man
foreign
became an Elden Lord for three months
let's go thank you welcome
I think that might just be a renewal and
you're not actually here but if you are
I appreciate it thank you
yep that just didn't go well Chet
that was bad
I don't have a summon
so what the frick are we talking about
what the flip dick are we talking about
this is what I want
I'll wait I'll be patient
I'm smart
thank you
anyone else hate these guys
like even when they're not ghosties in a
boss fight
I think I find them so [ __ ] annoying
okay so Tara
physic
blue
comet
I don't need the blue
so that was kind of insane holy [ __ ]
wow bro all right now I'm gonna slice
them up
oh that attack is so
foreign
I'll find any excuse to play bloodborne
Gray
I just wish it was at 60 frames
this is not a beat my head against the
wall print
not even remotely close to that
why am I getting a bunch of advice what
is happening right now it's fine
I just like have gotten hit instead of
not gotten hit that's literally what's
happened that's it
foreign
like how else would I melt them by not
you guys are confusing the [ __ ] out of
me right now
but the things you like want me to do
just doing this
thank you
okay
why is he not doing the thing he always
does
where is it [ __ ]
well that sucks
thank you
no wrong button
foreign
holy [ __ ]
okay what's with all the back seating
right now Chad what what happened to my
chat I'm sorry I'm I'm not good as a
sorcerer but [ __ ] man I know how to
fight Nile just not as a sorcerer
bewitching branches no I I just stop
oh
it's literally as simple as just don't
get hit
I don't like my like my spell setup
right now
I don't like it
we're squishy and we're worried well
just say like you know you're not
helping chat there you go
so just like maybe don't
it's the game's getting payback for more
got true
I'm just gonna blast his ass
I forgot to use the physic
well that was dumb
wow look at that
hi Stan
there we go
that time it worked out all right well
[ __ ] [ __ ] chat
dude your window is too big fix this
please
what about my window is bothering you
it's a window
fix what
let me get rid of the Sun for you my guy
I'm not spending any runes yet
it's also not a window it's a [ __ ]
porch door it's a it's a sliding door
has a new place it's fantastic and I
love it Stan
I don't know why I did that I'm gonna
teleport out anyway
such an offensive door
oh my God
I love when it when a Chatter's first
time in here they're just like
this is bothering me fix it
Jesus
255 here
canceled
great
sounds good
your window's too big fix it
I watched some anime
depends on the anime
nope I go right past this Dragon this
dragon's dumb
how was your date
uh she canceled on me Stan
so it didn't even happen
okay so how would you like to for me to
go about fixing the door for you Roberto
how how can I help you man
sorry I was looking at something
nah it's okay Stan
oh the only only
um
simply remove it
right
what am I trying to level chat
that's right
I wanted to use Ronaldo's
I was gonna consider visiting
what gave you the idea that I would want
you anywhere near my home
whoa
where did you get this idea
well
[Music]
yeah I should level mind good point
well the date didn't even happen so that
was probably a good thing Tim
it wasn't your choice
do you not understand how weird you're
being right now
or do you and I can ban you
ASAP Rocky
seven
uh
I know where to get a seven
do we have an eight and a nine
we have an eight
I know where to get a nine
or is this going to be pretty good for
now
you know what [ __ ] it good enough for
now
augers in the chat
all right
yeah I don't know if he's trolling about
the door either I don't think he's
trolling it doesn't seem like it it was
the first thing he said
so he's probably serious
yeah I know where it is in Caleb guys I
just don't want to go get it right now
that is simply it
might do that
I have not seen the new Puss in Boots
movie
I have not
I am offended by how much light is
coming in the window
please move the sun you know I I could
just close the blinds
maybe that's what he wanted
probably what he wanted
there are Gamers and they hate the Sun
true
hold on sorry chat
okay
I think I like the lighting
it was just the way he phrased it
I'm glad you like him Granny thank you
for watching them
the phrasing was made me yo what the
[ __ ] you talking about
your window is too big please change
okay I'm gonna drop the whole thing now
however me calling out the window
comment is deserved because that's just
stupid
foreign
should I just ban this gray feather guy
who said
I think he asked where I live I don't
think I answered and he's like oh
well I was gonna come visit and I'm like
why would you think I'd want you to come
to my home and he said it wasn't your
choice
that's kind of weird
easy 80k I don't like fighting bike
personally
no
man it's a joke that's the worst joke
I've ever heard
and I recommend not telling me to chill
when you're
quote unquote joking about coming to my
home unannounced
as a streamer content creator that's
really [ __ ] weird
think of the content that's not content
that's just really really weird
jellyfish Quest I think we'll be okay
without it
oh
okay so you guys wanted me to use this
spiral Shard thing
against the fire giant right
are you guys thinking about the spinny
sword that goes in your hand because
that's not that
I don't think but I could be wrong maybe
that's not what you're thinking of
okay level 83 fire Giant
we don't find out
not gonna be good on him he moved
this was the whole point
Alexander
I'm using them [ __ ] this boss
oh I can't use torrent though that's so
stupid
the entire point was this will be good
against the fire giant is what I was
told
I'm upset
so you're saying when he's staggered
yeah
so like right there
I didn't know he was rolling why are we
doing no damage
I'm not happy Chad
I want you to know this
hmm
you're saying physic huh
I see your point
I see your point
we didn't get a lot of opportunity with
that but it was something
come here
oh I'm dead cool
when does he ever use that [ __ ]
attack that close I'm sorry
this boss is so dumb it's insane
I will say that till the day I'm
shooting his head
[ __ ] you man
foreign
I've never shot his head before
I can't even reach
I'm upset
let's try this again
yeah common Azure is pretty much useless
without the physic definitely
can I retaliate his fireballs
or like when he shoots him at me
I'm def I'm not using a mimics here
not using one I probably want to use the
common Azure thing right here right
what are the odds this kills me
[Music]
I'm noticing that with this build the
chat is different
I'm noticing with this in this sorcerer
build that the people who are very
adamant about having certain things on
their character are just coming out of
[ __ ] nowhere
and I don't know how to feel about it I
think it's a type of person
come here Alexander
are you noticing that as well
definitely a thing
okay I'm Gonna Save the physic for stage
two and I'm going to carry and slice up
his ankle
we just want to see you win
again you're not helping
I promise
you're just not
weird movement
slice them up Danny
huh
Alex is just getting into the fight now
excellent
your chat secretly filled with wizard
mains
I guess so
I think you gotta play Super optimal all
the time
right
like you have to have your spells in the
perfect spot in the inventory
this amount of physics this amount of
whatever the [ __ ]
how about I just I'm a wizard
and I cast spells and [ __ ]
that's it
simple
and then when I get hit I die
I couldn't even see him
that was a weird move
I don't know if I've seen that before
the heck
excellent
the thing I hate most about FG is phase
two his hands on to beat the spots but
they move so much like bro just sit
still for five seconds
that's what I'm saying man
oh man
thank you sunshine how are you bro
couldn't agree more
thank you thank you
oh Alexander's down
oh my God you're [ __ ] delayed us
everything
just give me the stage two
okay
[Music]
no
[ __ ] it
no
no
no
it's like to Miami and they have for a
cruise
okay
let's go
I kiss I guess you can't roll it when
you're directly underneath the guy huh
flight to Miami in the AM for a cruise
that sounds awesome sunshine I hope you
get some some sunshine
see what I did there
and thank you for the two bucks
I appreciate it man thank you
[Music]
all right chat
I can do this can I I'm the best
we're the best music right
I don't know
still waiting for the bird
the bosses have more Health when you
when you use a summon right
maybe I could just kill him
foreign
no [ __ ]
oh Alexander
I could not have been in a worse spot
actually
this boss is just the best I love it
what the [ __ ] was that
it should still be a weak spot yeah
physic
Ally
and
how is that missing
Whatever video game
and I don't have torrent
how did that Miss chat
oh my
gaming
foreign
giant because I want distance
that's kind of cool
usually I can't
and now I'm dead
what does the game expect me to do there
when I don't have
I don't think you can run away from that
attack
oh
foreign
what
no he didn't do any any damage
okay there we go
yeah I can see the spiral will work in
there
definitely
but I already used the physic
Ally Alexander is huge for that fight he
is a massive
all right chat
let me upgrade my int
boom
I think that's gonna do it for me today
I gotta go see my parents I gotta pick
up dinner for them and then I gotta get
I'm bringing Joy back for tomorrow
so
that'll be nice
um
I'll be back on same time tomorrow
probably 11 A.M CST until around now
I don't know I'm gonna ask my parents
what they want and they can order it and
I I can pick it up on my way there so
um hope you all had a great day hope you
had fun
yep I'll be streaming tomorrow we'll
we'll continue this until we beat it I
want to do this until we beat it
um should we change the title of the
stream you aren't only upgrading Vigor
read it again Trey
so many people have done that today read
it again 500 members equals Vigor only
run
I don't I think that's I don't know a
lot of people are missing that
I'll change the title afterward
obviously but that's during the Stream
um
yep we'll be back tomorrow
we'll go again
and uh that's it
I'm in your walls dude that's two people
now I'm Banning you I'm sorry I I'm not
doing this [ __ ] that's just really
[ __ ] weird where's the other guy who
did the same thing
I'm scrolling to you now
all the way
there you are gray feather boom done
gone that's just weird [ __ ]
I hate that
all right anyway
have a great rest of your day chat
I'll see you all tomorrow thanks for
hanging out and uh we'll continue this
guy so peace and love I'll try and get
the the frame rate fixed I don't know
what's going on with that
um with the internet and stuff but
hopefully
um it's just that I had to change a
couple settings and we'll be good so
bye